[Applaudissements]
jean luc est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce qui s'est passé on avait on
a un arc et des flèches et donc c'est un
franchement c'est pas de moi
jean luc et c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est que ben c'est la faute des
dirigeants de des huit avant tout parce
que s'il n'avait pas fait encore games
mais plutôt la petite maison dans la
prairie on s'en serait pas mais ça n'a
pas en bien c'est donc il s'est dit
tiens
est ce que quelqu'un pourrait mettre une
bouteille sur sa tête oui évidemment il
a un qui accepte et tu comprends pas le
projet et les images on a les images
regardez sa cellule alors c'était tout à
l'heure j'étais garé à l'instar regardez
donc voila vous au lit donc ça ça aurait
pu s'arrêter là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais rien n'avait rien donné
on est en train de comprendre qu'il
voulait lui viser la gueule des pétards
et comme il est une bouteille c'est la
vexer s'est dit on va faire plus fort je
vais faire tomber la bouteille qui est
pas sur ta tête tu allais plus bouté sur
sa tête et vous ce qui devait arriver
est arrivé
côté ambiance et ils doivent viser le
front des fonds mécontents en plus à
regarder et ne fait pas chez vous ne le
faites pas c'est nous savamment corner
11e corps mais oui il est bon camarade
parce que il est bon camarade y prend la
flèche dans la gueule j'étais à côté il
se tenait il avait mal et au lieu de se
plaindre il a fait quelques lycées
relevé quand même comment tu as fait
pour toucher la bouteille ouais c'est ça
la